can europe have a military power of its
own the war in ukraine has pushed many
countries in the continent to ramp up
their defense spending
but is that enough to counter external
threats this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
hasam seeker russia's invasion of
ukraine has triggered policy shifts
across europe among them a change in
germany's policy on military spending
for more than 30 years the defense
budget has been a low priority for
german governments but in the words of
german chancellor olaf schultz russia's
actions in the continent marked a
turning point in how his country views
itself in europe in a historic shift he
committed to raising germany's military
spending to two percent of its gdp
that's more than a hundred and eleven
billion dollars schultz also said
germany would supply ukraine with lethal
weapons opening the door for many of its
allies to do the same
under military agreements germany has
for years banned weapons it sold to its
partners from being transferred into
conflict zones
we are experiencing a turning point and
this means that the world after this is
no longer the same as the world before
it in essence it's a question of whether
power can break right whether we allow
putin to turn back the clocks to the
time of the great powers of the 19th
century or whether we have the strength
to set limits to warmongers like putin
we will set up a special bundeswehr fund
for this purpose and i am very grateful
to the federal finance minister for his
support on this the 2022 federal budget
will provide this special fund with a
one-time sum of 100 billion euros and we
will use this fund for necessary
investments and armament projects from
now on year after year we will invest
more than two percent of the gross
domestic product in our defense
in times of peace countries rarely
allocate more than five percent of their
gross domestic product on military
spending but when there's a war that
rises let's quickly take you through
some comparisons for context during the
last year of the second world war the
united states defense spending was about
40 percent of gdp
in 2020 it was less than four percent
the united kingdom's military spending
in peacetime fluctuates around 2.5
percent at the height of the second
world war the uk was spending around 53
percent of its gdp on its military
there's no clear data on how much france
spent between 1940 and 45 though it's
estimated to have been between 40 and 60
percent france spent two percent in
2020.
germany is estimated to have spent
around 50 more than seven decades ago
two years ago it was 1.5 percent
for more on this i'm joined by our
guests in kharkiv ukraine is maria of
deva specialist on eu ukraine relations
and head of research for the european
expert association in london
andrea
andreas creek author and senior lecturer
at the school of security studies in the
defense studies department at king's
college and joining us from brussels
theresa fallon
director at the center for russia europe
asia studies teresa is a former member
of the advisors group nato sakura
well thanks very much uh for joining us
so um maria if i could start with you uh
presumably this is welcome news
uh in key of the germany the the biggest
economy in europe is going to ramp up
its uh defense spending but i want to
ask you as well since you were talking
to us from there um at the time
of of us recording this there have been
some large-scale attacks on uh kharkiv
uh hopefully you are you are safe but i
just want if you could talk to me about
what the what situation is there and
what the atmosphere is like for people
there
yeah so thank you very much for having
me uh russia is shelling harkin for six
days already and uh yesterday and today
it was especially intense so
yesterday we have seen that russian
great rocket systems were used
deliberately and targeted
against uh residential areas in kharkiv
and we have confirmed 12 uh civilians
dead and among them two children one of
the rockets got into the car where the
family was at the moment and the car
completely burned out so uh they were
deliberately targeting uh residential
areas and the uh facilities for uh for
normal infrastructure like gas
infrastructure water infrastructure
that means that putin
sees that his blitzkrieg tactics didn't
work uh as he probably was
thinking about and now he is taking the
whole one and a half million city as
hostages and trying to blockade the city
because people are because of the
constant challenge
completely uh locked to where they are
that's basements shelters uh
metro so they are sleeping there and
standing there for the whole day and
night there is shortages of food
supplies water supplies medical supplies
and it's not possible now to bring it to
the city because of the constant
challenge and today uh was especially
striking because uh at 8 00
a.m in the morning
russia launched rocket to the building
or the main administrative building in
kharkiv which is situated in the central
square uh and which was the symbolic
place for kharkiv because it's where
they are the our flag is and all the
local government
is situated there so the building now is
completely destroyed uh the uh there the
latest uh the latest reports say that uh
the ten people are buried under the uh
under what was left from the building
and uh the uh selling continues i myself
had to move to corridor over in my house
because i have heard very close the the
the the uh the sound of the uh
aircrafts and the bombardiers or uh or
other kind of aircrafts very close
supplying and you know
uh bombing and shell in the residential
areas in kharkiv so that's completely
seen in ukraine as an act of genocide
against ukrainian people and russia is
in committing right now of war crime and
we are
really looking forward that this case
and hague will be uh will be
followed very quickly and that the uh
russian officials that are responsible
for that uh will be known as the war
criminals
andreas krieg how significant a shift is
this for germany
for for now it's just a narrative right
i mean germany has had had it very
difficult after the cold war to actually
define its resolved
where does it stand uh found actually
very difficult to define its foreign
security policy post
post world war ii but obviously was
quickly embedded into nato and then
really uh kind of followed the nato lead
because it was really the ground zero of
the cold war but obviously as the you
know the iron curtain came down and you
know we have this expansion into eastern
europe of the european union germany
never really defined what it actually
stands for it's a country that for the
most part defines its foreign policy by
or conducts its foreign policy by
commercial interest in advancing
commercial interests even the european
union has been a a means for the
industrial complex in germany to advance
its interests but beyond that in terms
of values in terms of actually
geostrategic interest germany hasn't
really defined who it actually is and it
has played as a much smaller uh uh role
in europe and in the security
architecture of europe than it's
actually weight uh economic weight in in
in europe and now what we see is a new
narrative emerging for the first time
germans are thinking about actually the
entire policy towards russia has failed
and they're now trying to rethink that
but for now we you know we need to be
very careful here i mean the german
government is a coalition government um
the the chancellor has made a speech
without actually talking to the various
parties in the coalition and and and
think about what it actually is that
germany wants to achieve so for now this
is is
fairly hollow and the problem of germany
again is not about how much money it's
spending because it has spent money but
it's how it's spending the money and
most importantly how it defines itself
what is the resulting what does germany
stand for and you know that's what a
strategy is all about strategy is about
first and foremost defining your grand
strategic narrative defining your ends
and your objectives before you actually
then go and developing capability which
is which is something that that germany
is lacking obviously as well
theresa fallon is this also uh the
recognition of a new reality in europe
first of all i just want to say i heard
part of the last speaker's comment so i
hope i don't repeat anything he has said
and i also want to just salute maria i
watch you on other networks and i'm just
amazed at your bravery in regard to
europe yes
putin's moves in ukraine have galvanized
opinion across europe germany is the
largest
country in europe the most powerful and
the fact that they have announced these
changes i think is very very important
some have seen it as a little too little
too late if they had announced these
sanctions and these actions this would
have could have prevented putin's
calculus for invading ukraine but we are
where we are now and i think that this
is a very key moment it's the first time
in the history of the eu that they will
actually fund weapons this is a huge
watershed moment and i think that um
i heard an official yesterday at a
conference date that the first time in
20 years
he feels proud of europe's common
security and defense policy known as
csdp it so that means in 20 years he
never felt proud of it until what
happened now so i think that we're
seeing
a tectonic change in europe which is
very important uh germany yes uh it's
good that they've agreed to this but
they agreed back in 2006 to meet two
percent of their gdp uh
to and they haven't done it so
announcing that they're going to do that
now yes give them a pat on the back but
they promised to do this since 2006 and
i think that they have fallen into line
because they see what is happening in
the neighborhood and that they have no
other option so
putin has gotten far more than he
expected a more united europe uh more
support for nato and a germany which is
no longer sitting on the fence and if we
zoom out a bit this has much larger
ramifications for germany's relationship
with china therefore the rest of europe
because germany is the biggest trade
partner of china in europe and they
since the february 4th uh signature of
the shi putin agreement many have seen
that as a non-aggression pact and so
we've seen putin move troops from
russia's far east after meeting with xi
jinping in beijing before the olympics
and he's able to move troops towards
ukraine he couldn't do that unless he
had agreement from china and in addition
you know they both were the same kind of
color suit shirt and tie they're
coordinating far more in space and other
areas and in that agreement it's a 5000
word agreement
china said that they supported russia's
moves in regard to nato that they would
also build a pipeline and also um you
know there is a question mark over china
how
will they act will they really help uh
russia so the biggest loser in this is
probably russia because they will be
far more a junior partner to china than
they ever dreamed of maria abdeva if
putin was trying to weaken and divide
nato he's done the complete opposite now
hasn't he hasn't he strengthened and
united europe against him
absolutely
the strategy of russia uh was aimed all
the time to find vulnerabilities inside
europe and try to use them and they were
pretty successful in some countries
doing that and they used it for for that
disinformation uh a lot and uh what he
sees now i think he didn't expect to see
that europe is now united and
he he
so he now says that the only means
russia has for now to threaten further
is to use of nuclear weapons because he
said yesterday that he is putting the
nuclear weapons uh
system on high alert and also this is a
question that is discussed in uh russian
uh no media uh media and uh that means
that that is the only option and putin
now has to threaten further because he
sees that his strategy is not working
and the nato countries and the alliance
and the europe is more united than ever
and you probably know that president
zielenski made an appeal to you for uh
the for ukraine to be part of the
european union and
the process is of course will be not
quick but then uh it means a lot for
ukrainians because
what makes us more strong is that we see
that we have support from all other
countries across the world and support
both like in terms of generally support
to the people but also support in
weapons supplied in
flight or jet supply in economic
sanctions harsh economic sanctions on
russia you know switzerland which was uh
always a neutral country it has
sanctioned putin and the last time they
did it was uh
against hitler uh in during the world
war ii so we see now that uh
the world sees uh putin and his regime
as a threat to the whole world and that
means that
he will be fighted and
my guess is that this uh he will lose
this game because he has actually not
a lot to put on the table and the
protests inside russia are growing
because yeah okay uh if i could turn to
andreas now um how
uh how much public support
does does this uh policy change have and
not just in germany but throughout to
europe i mean we saw those protests in
berlin uh the day before uh there does
there does seem to be a a certain amount
of popular support for this doesn't
there
yeah no i mean it's a it's a rallying
moment across european capitals we've
seen definitely public expressions of
solidarity with ukraine which is is is
is at least uh some source of um of of
hope that things might turn into the
right direction but we shouldn't be
completely fooled i mean there is there
are minority and fringe groups uh with
minorities and french groups in in
europe within the european union that um
the previous speaker already alluded to
that have been uh courted by the
russians and have kind of taken a
pro-russian position and many of those
people in the uh cynical anti-western
camp particularly anti-american
anti-they call an american imperialist
camp are still in the camp of russia and
they are not condemning russia so
i think why the majority vast majority
is very much on the streets to support
ukraine ukraine the russians have really
invested for many many decades also in
germany into uh groups on the far left
and the far right um to kind of take up
um the russian cause and support putin
um and this kind of cynicism has you
know even in german parliament we've
seen pablo uh people within the left of
the ruling um social democratic party
and the left party as well still taking
a very very strong pro-putin standpoint
and obviously most famously schroeder
the former chancellor of germany also
social democrat is still serving um on
on on russian energy companies boards
and he's still a very close friend of
putin so there is quite a lot that needs
to be done and i think there is also
that is something that worries me a
little bit because i think the the left
within this current german government is
still not necessarily on board of uh
with that militaristic um posture that
chancellor charles took in that speech
and i think a lot of discussion will
still have to happen and also that goes
to the german public more widely the
german public more widely is pacifist is
anti-militarist and for them to actually
swallow not just 100 billion being spent
but then that and that's the more
important question then actually
allowing the military to take a more
proactive expeditionary position i don't
see that happening at the moment because
i think the again resolution of germany
is post world war ii very much against
war against the use of hard power and it
will take some time to for that to
actually sink in and people to mobilize
and saying uh we we we want to take a
more hard power stance and let's not
forget those people on the streets in
germany in berlin and cologne over the
last couple of days they are protesting
against war that also means against
rearmament against the use of arms and i
think that will be an obstacle in
germany actually ever taking a more
proactive position in the in in the
likes or with the likes of france the uk
or the united states
well let's put some of that to
teresa then um
germany has historically been averse
hasn't it to having a larger stronger um
military is it is it
the scars of world war ii and
will as as uh andrea suggests
will it take time for the german many in
the german public to digest that
well many analysts have noted that
angela merkel for example would take
advantage when the public opinion had
shifted like this to really drive a new
policy and so that's what appears to be
happening i mean well the proof is in
the pudding but i really think that this
has been a galvanizing moment because
people are watching a war in their
living rooms on their television screens
and they can't believe it was happening
so i think that people as the um german
free democrat finance minister said it's
an investment in our own freedom that
they have to understand that they can no
longer be so pacifist uh there was a big
debate even you know as everyone knows
they only sent 5 000 helmets to the poor
ukrainians and that became a meme and a
joke and germany felt rather humiliated
by that there were howitzers that were
built uh when in eastern germany when
germany was divided and because of rules
and regulations you know had been sent
to estonia estonia had to ask permission
from germany if they could send it to
ukraine and they said no that was kind
of an easy no-brainer they could have
just let the estonians send it they had
no money had to change hands nothing but
there was such strong disagreement on
that so i think the
the perimeter has moved dramatically in
germany and i think the public we've
seen the protests and i think that this
idea of you know russia's influence
carefully cultivated influence network
uh across europe has crumbled we've seen
all of these former leaders who are on
the boards of russian companies you know
there are articles in in leading
newspapers citing all of these german uh
austrian british leaders who are on
russia's payroll and they have resigned
from their positions and as andrea noted
uh former german chancellor schroeder
has not so he's kind of a weird outlier
but he's been you know at eating at the
russian trough for quite a long time now
and i think that this has the unintended
consequence you know sunshine is the
best for transparency and this idea of
austrapolitique this under willy braun
this idea of
germany turning towards the east
trading more with russia will make them
more peaceful towards them all of this
has just been blown out of the water so
the fact that germany is 55 reliant on
german and russian energy is
unbelievable i remember in the 80s when
ronald reagan was warning germany no
more than 25 tops 30 percent uh
dependence on russian energy so 55 i
don't care if your neighbor's canada you
should diversify you should not be
reliant on any one country for that
amount of energy so i think there has to
be a rethink and this was also uh
chancellor schultz announced funding for
two emergency lng plans these take a
long time to build but it means that
liquefied natural gas plants will be
built so that they will diversify their
energy so i think that germany is really
taking a massive change when you look at
they wouldn't even allow some howitzers
and they were only pledging helmets so i
think that yes it's a bit late but it's
a very promising change and i think this
is all part of the strategic narrative
of europe they're coming up with their
own strategic compass
maria abdeva from where you sit do you
feel that europe should have seen this
coming
yes i think that
if ukraine has been given the nato
membership in 2008 when russia started
war against georgia so now we will be
discussing possibly different
issues you know and that will not happen
russia's aggression so i think that
so that was a big mistake and uh but we
are as we have already said with where
we are now and
uh
no uh before the uh invasion actually
ukraine asked for many times to already
to put severe sanctions on russia but
you know the countries of europe are
waiting uh until the uh russia will
actually invade and now we have this you
know war crimes here and the
humanitarian crisis on the verge of
beginning so uh what i would also like
to say is that the
uh why what could stop russia and what
could also uh make the support uh and
make the unity of the european countries
greater is that actually now we are
witnessing here the war crimes actually
because russia is killing civilians by
by the uh
by the uh weapons that are restricted
that are prohibited because
they used
vacuum bombs in city oktirka in sunski
region
near kharkiv so meaning that
is
having that in mind it might lead that
the
russian officials won't be uh you know
don't want to be uh in uh
in don't want to get into court as war
criminals and that probably they will
somehow try to uh now change the putin's
position on that and influence that and
that is why it is really important to
now to give in as much information to
the world as possible to what actually
is going on in ukraine because what
putin wants to show he is calling this
special military operation or sometimes
it's referred in western media as a
ukrainian crisis or russian ukrainian
conflict it is not it is russian war
against a sovereign state so that must
be put clear and when everyone knows is
on this position and understand that
russia will not stop in ukraine russia
already has full control over the
territory of belarus because it is
launching uh missiles and rockets from
the territory of belarus and ballistic
rockets as well yesterday were launched
from there and today we have information
that uh belarusian army is already on
ukrainian territory yeah so i say i
wanted to say that now they're really
close to the baltic states and to the
poland so what will be next you know
we're going to have to leave it there uh
thanks very much uh all three of you uh
for talking to us maria of deva in
kharkiv andreas krieg in london and
theresa fallon in brussels thanks very
much for being on inside story and thank
you as always for watching remember you
can see this program again anytime by
visiting our website at jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story
you can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle there is at aj inside
story for me hasam seeker and the whole
team here in doha bye for now